Hi there, Steve Kaufmann
here again in Palm Springs.
Um, today I want to talk about the 10
secrets to language learning success.
Uh, I even have a series of emails on
this subject, which you can subscribe to
and get into more detail on this subject.
Uh, remember if you enjoy my videos,
please subscribe to my YouTube channel
and click here for notifications.
And by all means, join me at LingQ.
Uh, I just wanted to mention too that,
uh, one thing that I discovered in
Vancouver was these, uh, aloo bukhara
Persian or Iranian dried plums or
prunes that are a little sour, a bit
like the Japanese umeboshi, and they
are delicious and they're very healthy
and they're popular from, I don't
know, Georgia, Turkey through to India.
And, uh, I bought them down
here and I really enjoy them.
I just had a couple of
before making this video.
So, you know, I can't rem...
quite honestly, first of all, when
people say that there's 10 secrets to
doing this, or six secrets or seven
secrets or three secrets, these are
ways to grab people's attention.
So that it's very common on the internet.
And if you Google, you're going to
find three, six, seven, 10 secrets
doing this, that, or the other.
And they are quite useful.
You know, they got 10 ways that
you can use baking powder or six
ways to, uh, keep moths out of your
closet or there's all kinds of these.
And typically it's, it's very useful.
You can click through them one after
another and it gives you ideas.
So even though it may seem a little bit
sort of, uh, the term now is clickbait.
Uh, I find that they're quite useful.
So I do encourage you to subscribe to
my, uh, email series of 10 secrets.
Uh, there aren't just 10 secrets.
There
aren't just 10 hints
on how to study better.
There might be five, there might be 20.
But I hope that each of these would
stimulate some thinking and maybe
each person finds their own 10
secrets to language learning, things
that they, uh, find help them become
more effective language learners.
But the absolute first one is the
famous three keys that I often quote
the, uh, again, I don't remember her
name, but she was the director of
the languages department at the San
Diego, San Diego state university.
And, and she said, you know, language
learning consists of three things, your
attitude or the attitude of the learner,
the time spent with the language.
In other words, not sitting in a
classroom, listening to explanations
in your own language about the
language, but actually being with the
language, listening, reading, speaking.
So time with the language, attitude, time
with language, and then this ability to
notice what's happening in the language.
Some people will hear the language and
just not notice how it's pronounced.
They'll continue pronouncing it the
way they think it should be pronounced
maybe based on the writing system
in their own language or whatever.
So we do have to be a little
attentive to the language.
So that's secret number one is
really, you know, buy into these
three keys to language learning.
The second thing is, you know, you got to
take charge of your own language learning.
You can't be dependent on a teacher
or expecting a school to teach you.
You have to drive the program.
What are you interested in?
Why are you doing it?
And then, you know, find things
that you find, uh, worthwhile
doing and then do them.
The third thing is words are
the key to language learning.
And that's  why at LingQ we track
how many words, you know, how
many words you have looked up,
how many words you've read.
Because again, when I was correcting
people's English, it wasn't
find points of grammar that made
their English less effective.
It was how they used words.
They didn't have enough words.
They didn't know which words belonged
with which other words, the whole thing
about languages is acquiring words.
And then getting used to how they
work, getting a sense of, you
know, the patterns of the language.
And that's all based on words,
words, and phrases, but phrases are
patterns, which consists of words.
Uh, also when you go to speak.
Again, you're speaking
words, you're speaking.
Meaning don't worry about how close
to native pronunciation you may have.
Of course, you're paying
attention to how the native speak.
You're trying to imitate it.
Some people get closer, some
people aren't quite as close.
It doesn't matter if you're
using words skillfully.
If you're using words, if you're
developing that feel for how words are
used in the language time, I mentioned
time, make the time, find the time.
And in that sense, listening is such a
powerful activity because it's helping
your brain get used to the language.
And it's also something that you can
fit in almost at all times of the day,
while in the car, on public transit or
washing the dishes and so forth and so on.
Find ways to motivate yourself.
Okay.
It might be the kind of
content you're doing.
Maybe you're motivated by doing
spaced repetition systems,
find things that motivate you.
Another thing is don't worry too much
about how long it's going to take.
If your focus is on enjoying the
process, then that how long it
takes will take care of itself.
You will move along more quickly if you're
focused on enjoying the process, rather
than if you're focused on how quickly,
you know, can I learn the language.
Another secret I think is to
not be too focused on how much
you can say at the beginning.
It's fun to speak.
It's fun to get feedback.
It's fun to interact with
people in a new language.
It's fun to try to put some words together
in a language that we're learning, but
ultimately what matters is how well can
you speak in six months or 12 months.
And that sense of major focus on
input, acquiring words, is going
to be more effective than using
the limited vocabulary that you've
acquired over and over and over again.
You have to expand beyond that limit
range, limited range of vocabulary
in order to engage with, uh, native
speakers in meaningful conversation.
Uh, and, and finally, you know, learning
a language is a, it's a process of
immersing yourself in a new environment.
The really, as I've said before, I'm not
sure there is a chapter one, chapter 10.
Yes.
Obviously, if you have more
repetition, it's going to be easier.
But at some point you're at,
you're looking at this lake or this
swimming pool, you just have to get
in and get wet, start somewhere,
start listening and reading, start
using the little bit that you can.
Immerse yourself.
And if you do those things, I think you'll
be successful as a language learner.
In the meantime, for more detail on
the 10 secrets of language learning,
and again, I'm not sure I've covered
all 10, but please subscribe to
my 10 secrets, uh, email course.
All right, then.
Thank you for listening.
Bye for now.